former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka and Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett
Greg let's start with you and the legal
side of this look it is a lot to take in
we take every bit of new text messages
now every night we put it with the old
text messages every night and put it
with other information that we've we've
gleaned over the year all facts now we
have a very clear picture of what went
on yes increasingly the evidence is
mounting now that struck and Paige and
others at the FBI we're engaged in
what's called a corrupt purpose that's
important because that's in the
obstruction of justice
statute so these messages reveal several
things one they knew the evidence
against Hillary Clinton was enough to
charge her second of all they changed
the language from charging her to
exonerating her and and third they did
it for political reasons because they
wanted her to be President they thought
she would be President they didn't want
to anger or alienate her did call me
struck Paige McCabe and Loretta Lynch
you all know ahead of time no charge
that's not a real investigation
you don't write exoneration before
investigation all right did they
obstruct justice
oh absolutely if they did it for a
political reason I think the evidence
demonstrates that they do any reason
thank you thank goodness for electronic
technology because this is the smoking
gun evidence of their motivations and
motivations is how you prove obstruction
of justice sebastian Gorka you were in
the White House story a lot of this time
I'm sure it took a lot of energy time
attention away from governing the
country maybe that was the goal of some
people the president still out a great
year but when you see the level the use
of FISA courts the weaponry of
intelligence when you see people at the
highest levels doing this to me it's
chilling as somebody that believes in
the rule of law equal justice under the
law and the US Constitution it is truly
chilling Sean as the child of parents
escaped a communist dictatorship where
the police was used for political
purposes and now that I'm a proud
American I I never thought I'd see the
day where the vaunted FBI people inside
that agency's senior management
individuals would be openly talking
about giving special treatment to an
individual they wanted to become
president we were in the White House I
was secure that there was no issue the
president told me they will find nothing
because there was no collusion we've
been accused of obstruction of justice
of conspiring with the Russians not one
piece of evidence and what do we know
today we now know that inside Obama's
FBI there was a conspiracy to pervert
the course of justice one woman who had
committed felonies it's not a question
as Greg has said you mishandled
classified information you have
committed a felony that individual was
treated with kid gloves given a pass and
then we know the FBI gives money to talk
about the media you're right in every
point it was great what about the media
they'll go with an anonymous source
about a story that never came to
fruition about Donald Trump you know the
case of Donald Trump was he's asking if
there's conflicts they say no he doesn't
fire and they make that big news with
all this evidence good let's put this
into context we are talking you're your
team you and your team have been doing
their heavy lifting every night in your
monologues or one day that data will be
used in a court of law to prosecute
these people I am sure of it but what's
the media doing in the meantime when
they're not colluding with these people
inside the Obama administration as those
text messages demonstrate what are they
doing just a week ago they're asking the
Vice Admiral the rear admiral who is the
president's surgeon whether he's still
drinking diet coke every day this is the
biggest scandal in modern American
history and the media either ignores it
or is complicit and that's the outrage
right do if presidents from percenters
robert muller have a conflict and
doesn't fire them how is that a story
it's a legitimate concern
again under the obstruction limit
legitimate concern of the president yeah
if the specialization for goodness sakes
I've written about it ad nauseam
you know journalists have been howling
for the last 24 hours
this is obstruction of justice by the
president those reporters don't know
anything about the law they've never
read the statute as I mentioned before
in a different context it requires a
corrupt act by the president that didn't
happen he was engaging in a legitimate
act according to the New York Times if
you believe them trying to remove Muller
because of his myriad of conflicts of
interests and replacing him with
somebody who would be legitimate
objective fair and neutral reasonable
thing that anyone would do right it's
not obstruction of justice these idiot
journalists and I watched them all
morning long they're not journalists
they don't know they're probably not and
they don't know a damn thing George
Oswald Greg right I alway have to do is
look it up it takes a nanosecond for
God's sake sheep the evil Luigi or the
little comprehend if they read it